les cadres infirmiers se sont joints au
mouvement lance aujourd'hui un mot
d'ordre de grève de trois jours
devant tant d'effervescence d'inquiétude
sur l'avenir de la profession est aussi
de récriminations sur la condition même
d'infirmières comment de toute jeune
fille se prépare-t-elle à ce métier
ont-elles encore la vocation chantal
kimmerlin l'a vérifié aujourd'hui dans
une école d'infirmières à paris a été
reconduit massivement par un vote à
l'unanimité assemblée générale amphi
bondé grève depuis les premiers jours
les élèves infirmiers suivent leurs
aînés se bat pour une meilleure qualité
de la profession d'abord au niveau du
recrutement que nous soyons recruter un
niveau bac ou sinon un examen
d'équivalence on enlève le capuchon
le bisou conséquences du malaise l'école
de la salpêtrière à paris n'a pas fait
le plein à la dernière rentrée 200
places en première année 170 inscrits
seulement le métier n'attire plus autant
de candidats et la déception des élèves
et des enseignants grosse si on demande
aux infirmiers d'être à la page d'être
toujours plus performant de toujours
douces toujours présent faut se
mobiliser cccc moralement c'est très
épuisant et on se rend compte que
malheureusement le reste ne suit pas on
se retrouve dans les services très peu
nombreux on s'épuise
on se fatigue et le malade empathie
c'est dommage qu'ils aient fait mes
études dans cette même école il ya
presque trente ans il ya trente ans
exactement puisque 56 et 58
je crois que nous avions plus
précisément peut-être une sécurité que
les chaînes ne ressentent pas
aujourd'hui yann on est acquis à l'école
inquiet pour l'avenir les conditions de
travail et le futur salaire pourtant la
vocation est toujours là et pour la
majorité des élèves c'est elle qui est
finalement gagnante
on voit les gens rentrés malades qui
souffrent qui ressortent avec le sourire
qu'ils nous disent merci
je pense que même si financièrement la
peu de choses on a beaucoup en voyant
ces gens sortir avec le sourire
l'école c'est trois ans d'études après
le bac les élèves infirmiers ont fait un
choix en y entrant celui d'avoir à leurs
yeux un métier et un rôle essentiel dans
la société